okay I never thought in a million years
that I would do this but I do believe in
maximum transparency
and so I'm gonna give you guys an
apartment tour
Julia Fox keeping it real I always keep
it real yeah she's giving fans a peek
inside her NYC apartment which is
surprisingly normal and kind of messy
so we can start in my bedroom which is
the living room so yeah I put my bed
here in the living room so maybe the bed
in the living room isn't typical but the
actress explains it's to give her
two-year-old son Valentino more room to
play so I could turn my bedroom into a
little playroom for Valentino
and she's got some furry residents too
we do have a little uh small mouse
problem but you know it it's a it's a
problem depending on how you look at it
you know I appreciate that they at night
while we're sleeping come out and clean
up the crumbs that my son drops on the
floor
so yeah I'm not gonna evict the mice
anytime soon next up on the tour this
very long hallway nothing happens here
just more
it's Valentino's little staycare
schedule
um just more stuff
um
Richie I love these photos then Julia
shares a glimpse of her new york-sized
bathroom and this is just my little
bathroom
it's very tiny but you know it does what
it's supposed to do this is my kitchen
area don't judge me I know oh cotton
candy machine I know it's really messy I
also have shoe boxes in the kitchen
which is very common for New Yorkers but
there's one room Julia says she put a
little more thought into this is
Valentino's room I put the most effort
in this room I think I pulled a little
Loft and I really wanted him to have a
cute room
however he does not hang out in here at
all he only wants to be in Mama's room
he like doesn't even sleep in there he
sleeps in bed with me yeah we're
Co-Sleeper sue me I don't care stars
there just like us
so why isn't Julia living large after
her uncut gems Fame for me personally I
just I don't like excessive displays of
wealth they make me feel it icky
um you know especially
people that have really big houses it's
just really wasteful when there's so
many homeless people in this country and
like I just I'm I'm not really like that
while it may be shocking to see a celeb
with a pretty normal home the star says
she's prepared for any slack she might
get online and I know I'm gonna get
roasted and whatever but hopefully maybe
someone can watch this and be like okay
well maybe I'm not doing so bad yeah
from the looks of it Julie is living
just like us Average Joe's yeah always
foreign